Jeane dubbed his own tap so don't
believe that somebody else did that for
him now the process of dubbing taps was
very very difficult gene hated to tap
danced in movies because of it because
what he had to do is these movies are
all shot to a playback they record the
music first and then they come in and
they performed - with Lilly music on the
Lilly horns - playback and then the tap
dancing has to be dubbed in after so
gene went into a booth with her headset
with a microphone dangling at his ankles
watched himself on the screen and had to
duplicate what he was doing and hit
everything and he said he had to be very
very careful not to get that wire
wrapped around his ankles to break his
ankles so he he also brought his
assistants in to try to come up with the
sound of tap dancing in water and you'll
read that that other people did that no
it was Jean it was just regular hard
taps but it was the great sound engineer
bill Saracino who came up with the kind
of squishy water sound that she'll hear
now the it is true that the water
pressure everyone came home from work in
Culver City and took a shower in the
afternoon and the water pressure went
way down so they had to cut off shooting
and then hang more rigging and and be
able to shoot the next day now Cyd
Charisse was never to be in the original
picture it was to be Donald O'Connor and
Jean in the final Broadway mount melody
but Donald had a previous commitment and
had to leave the picture and Debbie's
dancing wasn't sufficient to do a big
number like that so they brought Cyd
Charisse in now when you watch her this
was the first time ever that Sid had
danced to jazz music she was a trained
classical dancer and Jean said he had to
get her off point and to do jazz and
it's extraordinary what you see and he
modeled her after he had a childhood
crush on the great actress Louise Brooks
so he modeled her Bob and her costume
after that they the censors came in
repeatedly and would measure the
decolletage of the woman and the length
of the skirt
and gene would wait till they left and
in this you'll see that the green skirt
goes to her knee and then he slid it up
so you could have it's not salacious
it's just so you have the longest
extension of her leg which you must have
in that the scarf number was created
with the equivalent of three airplane
motors they're called Ritter fans for
those of you who are in that business
and gene I have photographs of him in
the archives where he had to actually
choreograph the Ritter fan operator to
hit him at just the right point so that
that fan would shoot up
he said the torque on his body as he
lifted Sid into the air was
extraordinary and had to turn her and
choreograph and make that hit so keep
that in mind and that was considered so
racy in many countries that that
sequence they figured out that it's
lovemaking and so in Spain they cut that
sequence out of the picture